right we'll just fire up the
stream live stream that is good
afternoon councillor staff and those
joining us on the live stream we're
reconvening
the extraordinary performance policy and
partnerships committee meeting uh that
was adjourned last week as we deliberate
on the
annual plan submissions
um just to note that we have an apology
from councillor keith
and a note from reverend cook that she
will need to depart early at 3 50
on zoom councilor rabbit councillor
clark and reverend cook and uh mrs coote
welcome along
uh if i can start with
first of all asking patricia um there
were some questions that were raised by
councillor clark
um following the the first part of the
deliberations and there was a response
that has been circulated to councillors
but everybody else isn't isn't privy to
them i wonder if you could provide us
with
an overview of the questions and and
answers that were in that place
um thank you chair um so the number was
a number of questions that counselor
clark raised and i'm going to sort of
summarize them
as best as i can
without going into too much detail
so the first was in relation to the cash
reserves held by council and what they
were made up of
and at 30th of june
2022 we're forecasting that there will
be 37.4 million of reserves
of which 17.4 are restricted and 20
million are classified classed as
non-restricted by law
however either legislation or council
policies require these to be held in
cash
so of that 20 million
we've got 7.9 relating to special
purpose council created reserves
10.7 million relating to infrastructure
targeted rates funds
and 1.4 million in the investment
property and housing care so that's
where that 20 million is tagged to
and that's all detailed in the annual
report but the next question was in
relation to the 3.8 million of maturing
term investments that were drawn down
in the last quarter
and what they were used to pay for that
3.8 million at the time was used to fund
a share of stead street and the city
street streetscape works
um but i wanted to remind everybody that
council funds its capital for its net
debt accounts so therefore it's
necessary to ensure that we've got
sufficient liquid cash available to pay
our bills as they come due
so how council staff manage that is by
using a mixture of both borrowings and
cash reserves cash from rates
and
maturing term deposits
the next question was whether that 3.8
million affected a net debt position
um
and that it would have the net debt
position that 31 march 22
was 42.9 million we had 88.3 million of
debt
and 45.4 million of cash and cash
investments
and a forecast net debt position at 30
june this year is expected to be 38.6
million
93.7 million of debt
and
55.1 million of cash and cash of his
investments
and i provided councillors with a
breakdown of what that cash and cash
investments balance was
which is both term deposits cash
liquid loans that we have to icl at a
small amount of other investments
we also don't consider
that this that net debt change will
affect our double a credit rating
because we are managing within our cash
boundaries
and that was discussed at the last risk
and assurance meeting that we're trying
to maintain a minimum balance
of cash of 20 million
the next question was in relation to the
civic administration building upgrade
and whether this was the forecast in the
ltp is 16 million
but some reporting to risk and insurance
had indicated that this was 28 million
cost
we wanted to clarify the position that
the pmo dashboard presented on the 24th
of march march risk insurance committee
showed that was the current estimated
out turn cost of the project was
currently 28 million
the that number was used to highlight
the estimated financial risk to the
project without altering the scope or
undertaking mitigations to the cost
the ltp budget of 16 million has not
been changed through the capital
reforecast process and still remains the
approved ltp budget for the project
the project will come back to the
council next year before any physical
works are undertaken
also provided was how much has been
spent this year and what is forecast to
be spent
so a hundred thousand has been spent
today to the end of april and it's only
expected that it'll be 300 000 spent on
that project this year and 600 000 next
year
the last question
was in relation to that accounting
treatment of our government subsidies
and the impact on our unbalanced budget
and whether the
fact that now we were matching income
with expenditure
was fiscally neutral
the way that the the unbalanced budget
formula works as a calculation um
is that it takes a total revenue
operating revenue against their
operating expenditure
however the government subsidy income
is actually considered as operating
income
but it is used to pay
capital expenditure
so that's why it's not considered
fiscally neutral and we are matching off
our
expenditure for those subsidies against
the income
thanks patricia
so that's just an overview of the
information that
councillors were provided with and i
wanted to make sure
that that information was acknowledged
in the public arena
last week we got through to
and including recommendation six
um
i am guessing that a majority of the
discussion is going to come around item
15 so there are some
procedural notes that are in there that
we can look at taking as as one to
progress to that point if if you're
interested
councillor soper uh mr chair i'd be
happy to move that we take
recommendations seven to fourteen as a
block
seven through to fourteen
councillors you happy with that
councillor pottinger
no i'm not the reason i'm not happy with
that is because that assumes that
the forecast
rates increase is 7.15
now i disagree with that assumption and
i have reasons for that so
the reason if you adopt all of that you
then move into 15 which has levers to
reduce it further
but i i have reason good reason to
dispute 7.15
so then are you suggesting an amendment
that we take item seven to ten
yeah that would be fine as long as i
have an opportunity to
let this council know why
um the 7.15 is not correct thank you
sir a seconder for that amendment
councillor lewis
i'll put the amendment if you're
unsure it is we're moving to take items
seven to ten together
put that all in favor
against no
do you like your vote recorded counselor
so thank you thank you
the uh
amendment now becomes a substantive
motion so
we're now moving to take items seven to
ten together
um
moved again by councillor soper and
councillor sorry councillor pardinger
and councillor lewis
it's open for discussion
counselor partner okay to elaborate on
why i believe the 7.1 well hang on we're
just
actually at the motion now your
amendment is now the motion we're
getting to that next
so just on the amendment taking seven to
ten together okay
any questions or comments i'll put it
all in favor
against carried
which brings us to items eleven
councillor partner thank you chair um
look we we we're advised that there is a
solid waste increase of seven hundred
thousand dollars
um due to
increases in the emission trading scheme
cpi costs
involved in the actual collection
transportation
and
gate fee
now i was given the table
to break this down and what what the
components were in the seven hundred
thousand
and they are redman cost yellow bin uh
the
when i say yellow bin it's the
contaminated contaminated waste
that gets picked up from the move
and then there's a column for ets and a
colon for gate fee unfortunately it is
my
strong belief
that the ets has been
factored in twice and the reason i say
that
is that the gate fee
um speaking with the various people
involved
in
in this industry is that
it should be 202 for the gate fee
which includes the ets so
what i'm saying is that
there's a few hundred thousand dollars
that are added in there that shouldn't
be there in my calculations and also the
um
the prediction that the waste is going
to increase now that disturbs me because
there is no fact for that when i checked
up on the
figures
it showed that waste
flow out to av lime is static the
tonnage is static it is not increasing
so if you
and our job
for waste minimization is to not allow
waste to increase
so if you go to the waste net
website it'll say it's 650 per capita
that's our target
now the mfp would be aghast if we
are predicting
waste increases and not doing anything
about it
so if we
maintain
the current
tonnage of nearly fourteen thousand
and apply
um the correct gate fee charge without
the extra ets
that seven hundred thousand now becomes
four hundred thousand
okay three hundred thousand comes off
that
and which means that the one point one
seven rates increase
that's associated with
the solid waste
has now been reduced by 0.5
0.5 of a percent
okay so that are the facts
and um
okay counselor clark i see you've got
your hand up is it about the same item
before i go to seek an answer for that
fgr
i
um on the similar maintenance council
ponder i think we haven't explored the
uh
enough the
potential to keep the rates at four
percent we haven't uh
i'm just on waste net at the moment
because the rest of that is
is coming
rhiannon or patricia who would like to
have a kraken
a response for councillor pottinger's
point
so we have been since the last since
councillor punjab has raised this issue
we have been working with the team
about
the basis for the 700 000 and we've gone
back and looked at things and the team
are still telling me they believe they
need the 700 000
um
we are looking at the ets
numbers
um and that but that information only
came to me like this morning so i
haven't had a chance to fully delve into
those different
those different ones myself
but at this point what i'm getting from
the team in charge of solid waste is
that they believe that's still
the 700 is what was required
and that can i just ask that the ets
hasn't been
charged twice because it shows here in
the table that was sent to me
by staff
that's being charged twice
i have it in front of me
i i have
say i just went to transit whether i had
that table
that's the one you sent to me yeah
um i don't think it has been
um we double checked it um but i know
there is a report that we're trying to
pull together report to come back to
council
as soon as possible on this though we're
just trying to get the staff
available for it
okay i understand there are some
challenges around staffing at the moment
with a bit of illness
which is
thank you
there is no way the gate fee
of 204.65
is without
ets
no way there is no way at all
and the ets in that table that was sent
by you to me um
shows ets as listed separately and is a
component
of the a major component of their 700
000
i'll have to go back and look at it
counselor just that it's critical
because we're going to be setting the
rates today and if we are over charging
then i don't believe that's good it's
0.5
and if you add
if you had yet to be discussed and
debated um the options in 15
the levers that can be adjusted
that would drop the rates
down to 5.79
which which is quite significant
um thing and we get one shot at this
um
and that's done today a recommendation
to council unless
unless we go to
adjourn it and do it again but look
these figures
um
that i have show
that the ets has been charged twice
councillor soper
thanks mr chia i i just for a point of
clarification
why are we discussing this under
um recommendation 11
uh the reason i brought that up uh
council is over was because that it sort
of sets the trend for 7.15
i'm looking through this as an
opportunity
to
change that 7.15 and then you'd carry on
and do the rest of it
i'm sorry councillor pottinger but you
moved recommendation 10
which has the 7.15 noted it doesn't
substantiate it that's why i left it to
11.
so i'm not going to be caught out by
any tricks or anything this is this is
moving forward with 7.15
so we need to work out if that 7.15 is
correct
mr chair my point is we could discuss
this under recommendation 15
which will be the more appropriate place
to discuss it and possibly amend that
recommendation rather than discuss it
under recommendation 11.
right i would tend to support that and
that there is still the flexibility
under 15 to go back and review those
percentages if we're able to find
mechanisms for reducing you're
comfortable with that concept look if if
that is still
if you're waiting to to ascertain
whether that uh solid waste thing is
correct and you're prepared to put it
into 15
as a you know as a lever then i would
accept that thank you
mrs hadley did you have something um
mr chair i have
and i'm just trying to get the officer's
attention
but i have received advice that the
initial advice was that it was double
counted
but subsequent workings show 700k is
still needed at this stage
patricia i think has made the point we
need to do more work
i would just point a clarification chair
so it's still needed
so when you say still needed it means
that oh wow um okay we've double counted
it but
we still need some extra money as well
and this is in this needs to be added to
this table that i have
i can't it seems like a moving feast
there is still more work to be done in
understanding the exact ins and outs
within solid waste
and i think counsellor you raised a
couple of questions around that which at
the chairs meeting previously which will
result in a report i'd take your point
that um
it is a
another mechanism for looking at where
we can save costs but at the moment
we're actually looking around items
11 to
[Music]
whatever next
um
i'll agree with it if it's if it's going
to be factored into 15. yes yes
i think everything's on the board when
we get to item 15. yep okay thanks
so with that in mind counselor sopher
with that in mind mr chair i'm happy to
move
recommendations 11 to 14.
thank you is there a second for that
council
any discussion
if not i put the vote all in fair
i against carried which brings us to
item 15 now councillor clark i cut you
off earlier before so i think this would
be an appropriate time to to bring you
back in with the points that that you
were wanting to raise
you're on mute
counselor it was just to uh
become involved in the the debate on
what levers are available um certainly
section 15 is nowhere near wide enough
for me
and i've got other suggested levers that
we could be using um
but councillor partners quite right
that
if if we need to do more work and
potentially there's seven hundred
thousand dollars
worth of costs going at the solid waste
that may not need to be incurred that's
about a third of the money that we need
uh 700 000 was the total amount yes
councillor pottinger was suggesting not
that full amount
okay that's fine
so are we into the debate on um what
levers could be available to us
we are
yeah excellent
um
so um
i've got two or three to consider
so my position having listened to the
debate is that we should still only
factor in
four percent because that's uh
reflective of the
pain that's been suffered in the
community around food fuel
power and rent slash mortgages
so some other things that we we could
consider can we take them individually
counsellor would it would that would you
be okay with that if you're okay so the
first one is uh by my
for my suggestion we wouldn't do any
work on the
civic administration building until
we knew
what the future of local government was
going to be and that may be some time
away it seemed reckless to me to be
potentially putting 600 000 next year
according to the advice of
patricia
and into a building that we don't know
what the
long-term future is for it
so um given that we need 1.8 million to
bridge the gap between
4
and the 7.15 that's now in the report
that's a third saving just in that one
area lane
can i ask um
mrs hadley with the work the maintenance
work that has been
at minimum delayed for quite a few years
now
um
where does that leave the risk profile
of the building currently
thank you mr chair i'd need to check in
relation to compliance matters i know
there is an uh an issue relating to the
tying of the stairwell
um i think the piece of advice that
you're really looking for
is one that comes from finance because i
think that this is a very small item in
terms of op-ex
and comes from a renewal budget so it
doesn't actually have a big impact on
the rates increase
that would be correct so this is coming
from this is a capital funded project so
a reduction in capital of 600 000
has
near to nothing no impact on rates next
year
thank
you counselor
well i'm not sure i agree with that
advice that was given
um
we can jump around this debate as much
as we like between opex and kpegs but at
the end of the day it still requires
funding so if you don't spend in one
area be at opex or capex surely it must
lighten the need for additional rates a
good example is when we approved
um
quite some time ago to extend
stage two of streetscapes
we were revised and that's a that's a
capex project we advised them no
uncertain term what the percentage
increase would be to rates so i just i i
struggle with the advice now that if you
offset costs and capex then it has no
impact on rates because at the end of
the day
it's too difficult to separate those two
out i understand the depreciation of
impact and how that funds some work but
streetscapes is a good example where the
advice we were given was if we approved
stage two which went up s street
um towards the civic administration
building that there would be an impact
for rates so i don't see why and how the
similar capex work on the edmond
building would be any different
and i guess the other issue is that an
advice that i got
on that project from patricia
i and she read out a summary of that i
was unclear about
what she was saying about
the long-term plan saying that the
project to upgrade the building
is 60 million dollars but in the
dashboard report that the risk insurance
committee gets it was predicted that
that cost would be 28 million dollars
could be and uh so i guess the issue for
that is
i think she used words
for me the issue was well the treasury
the advice that we get through risk and
assurance um
one of those two reports has to be in
conflict with the other
so so if i can i can just draw pause for
a second there counselor
um
the
uh
report said could be 28 million
it's been reaffirmed that the budget
currently sits at 16 point whatever
council will determine that
i know from
pcg meeting though it was in last week
that that point was was
reinforced so
there is the potential if you went blue
sky thinking to
push out to
28 million but the budget is still set
at 16 patricia is there anything you'd
like to respond with um so you um
correct in relation to what that
reference to that 28 million was it was
a high number that it could get to
without mitigation in relation to
street the rates increase on streetscape
that you mentioned councillor clark
that was the total impact would take
into account having to repay the capital
and the interest on the borrowing has
resulted from that project
why i'm saying delaying the 600 000
spend on the cab
refurbishment next year is that 600 000
worth of borrowing and there's really
very little interest on that in the
first year
because you're not going to spend it all
in july
so that that's why i'm saying it's got a
very small impact on rates for next year
well just in response to that
if i may
um
again i don't understand the logic of
that advice so what we're saying is that
we would borrow 600 000
to do some upgrade work on a building
and and people will argue with that's an
operational cost given it's uh it's
dealing with repair and maintenance type
issues or whether it's capex but either
way patricia is saying that the
borrowing
the actual cost is only the
payments that come on the borrowing but
of course if we if we borrowed the same
amount the 600 000 and didn't use it for
the
upgrade but used it for some of the
components that are within the
extra money that staff have asked for
the extra
um
1.8 million dollars that we need to find
then surely that takes the pressure off
pushing the rates up beyond four percent
michael
yes through yourself
through yourself chair um just want to
get some clarification out there in
relation to the capital works
the works associated to the cab
obviously around the
refurb project itself
therefore they're around the design
aspects that we need to undertake within
that project
so there's
as most of that work will not be
physical works at the time they'll be
around the design components that will
have be happening next year
hence why we will need to come back to
council in the new year
as a rough guide for council so address
the other item in relation to rates
there's a very rough guide for council
that's six hundred thousand if you're
talking operational you can potentially
use one percent as a rough guide but i
say it's a rough guide we need to work
through those numbers need to be worked
through from finance when you're talking
capital projects it completely depends
on the funding source
if the funding source is through
borrowing and therefore affects rates it
is at most in that first year 0.01
impact
that's that's why finance is
recommending it is quite light
and it can be even lower depending on
the timing in relation to those capital
works
hopefully that gives some clarification
to that issue
thank you what was the next point you
wish to raise counsellor
to defer or to deny
a million dollars worth of uh three
waters for renewals so let's not say we
don't do it but we don't need to do it
next year
and i guess the philosophy behind this
we've already deferred a significant
amount of three waters
um
renewals to satisfy the need for extra
funding to go to the branson upgrade and
i
was in support of that but it's not a
big ask to
um
to take the
five six or seven million dollars that
was transferred across to brent's home
to add another million dollars to soften
the blow on the impactful rates this
coming year
patricia is there a response that you're
able to give
i would have to go and work out what
that rate's impact would be but
um on that on that but i suspect it's
probably not huge
but i can get we can get the team to
calculate it what about the
potential um
response uh from audit with the work
program that we've indicated and and
deferral are there implications to set
within that clear
look i think any time that you've
identified work and asset management
plans
for the ltp
and then you start pulling them out
there's a question about the quality of
your planning
given the scale of the budget overall
i don't think a million dollars would be
a deal breaker
i do just want to say that um
once we are an entity
it's very easy for the focus to be on
christchurch
and i'd want to be very i want you to be
very comfortable that by not doing that
work next year
you weren't actually creating a problem
for your residents in future years of
the work not actually getting done
because of it not being seen a priority
within the new entity
thank you michael
so sorry sorry council i'll come back in
just a second
through yourself chair just putting my
delivery hat on at the moment
um just want to remind council on this
annual plan you have made the adjustment
of 75 delivery target down to 70
which probably takes into account
roughly that sort of number in our
renewals program we don't quite know
where that's coming from at this stage
but we know
delivering 70 of the renewals program is
still going to be a challenge as well so
you're suggesting that partially
that suggestion is already being enacted
yes correct
okay councillor clark then i'll come
back to councillor pottinger
certainly um so in the renewals area i'm
not sure i agree with the advice given
while she began
um she was quite right to say the
million dollars in the oval scheme of
things there's not much
but it is two-thirds of what we are
trying to seek today
um and the other issue is it's all very
well to say well we've we've got
commitments in the long-term plan to
projects the auditors have suggested
that our um our long-term plan is
ambitious i think they were the words
they used
um and given that we've now got pressure
and given that in that long-term plan we
committed to four percent not 7.15
and given that our community how now has
pressure from a lot of other sources
i think it's quite appropriate for a
council this size with um the amount of
the work that we're doing which is
115 million dollars worth of uh
operational funding over a year to make
a one million dollar adjustment is not a
big ask if it keeps the pressure off
great players
councillor partner
look just a bit of clarity around that
um spending on three waters i spoke
extensively with the
chair of infrastructure from tuning city
council jim amali
and they he said they are pouring as
much into three water spend as they can
because they want to get it done
now
and then they'll transfer the debt once
the entity takes it the debt goes with
it but they want the work done they want
to know it's done and that's basically
what we should be doing too thank you
reverend cook
yes mr chair given that we have just
recently passed a stormwater bylaw
i would be exceedingly distressed if
the um proposal takes money away from
stormwater infrastructure because it's
something that obviously has some impact
on
water quality in the estuary and
further on
um
it's not just a number it's actually a
real project that will be
impacted on if we make this decision i
would be
interested to know
what
projects are going to be impacted
because i think for us to take a million
dollars out of say stormwater when we've
just passed a stormwater bylaw would
make a nonsense of the work that we've
been doing
counselor sofa
thanks mr chair i also want to speak
against deferring or delaying a million
dollars three waters renewal
for me it almost comes down to a point
of um
the morality
of air and the philosophy behind our
decisions on the three waters issue i
agree with the dunedin city council
approach this is essential work as um ms
cook says it it deals with water quality
issues that are of great impact and
importance to our ratepayers
for me
the idea that we would actually defer or
delay a million dollars of that work
into some nebulous future when we have
the opportunity as councillor pottinger
has pointed out and as dunedin has
emphasized of getting the work done in a
timely manner
and passing on the debt to the new
entity
why would we defer and delay such
important work a million dollars is not
small change a million dollars is
important in our water quality and our
delivery of three waters to our
ratepayers and i just want to emphasize
we are still at this point
a responsible council for that three
waters work that we have already planned
to actually
defer it in this ad hoc manner to me
is as i say almost
a
morality principle let's not do it
thank you i understand that the
temptation raised by councillor clark's
suggestion if there's a new body let's
let them deal with it but i'll
reaffirm a risk that was pointed out and
that
it's likely to be a particularly sizable
entity
and
in the motto that it's going to be
covering
are a lot of issues and i don't think
that ours are going to
rate particularly highly and i think
there is a risk if we
hand over um
work waiting to be done it may go on to
a longer never never however that's
that's where i'm sitting at the moment
i'll just just sorry
if you if you can be with me uh chair
um i struggle with some of the comments
made by leslie in relation to ad hoc
manner and morality i didn't hear those
comments from the member
when the staff moved i think somewhere
between five and six million dollars
worth of renewals
funding across to
the brinks home project
and at the time i did have some
discussion with michael about that um so
it's it's a bit rich to be saying well
we can't can't hold back another million
because the quality of our water will be
will be damaged well it's not the
quality of water it's the deliverability
of the water of the pipes first
the standard of water has not gone up
yet that's yet to come and so i guess
um suggesting that it's an ad-hoc manner
or has some degree of morality it's a
bit rich when we've moved five times
that amount and nobody made it made any
opposition
thank you
right
so
the suggestions been made uh is there
any appetite for it
indicatively is anybody supportive of
deferring that work
one other counts two councillors
um can i speak no i'm not okay
so effectively
what we are doing
is borrowing
to
subsidize optics now for me accounting
101
says you don't do that you either cut
your expenditure or increase your
revenue that's
quite
straightforward now
it was an interesting comment made by a
general manager of finance michael day
during a workshop we had and it made a
lot of sense is that
borrowing two million dollars doesn't
affect our double a
rating
with the bank
but
when the bank asks what the money is for
and they found out it was for optics
then
that would be a different story
so
you just don't borrow for optics
full stop with me you just don't do that
you get on and either find cuts or you
find new revenue
but you don't borrow it's just
instead of their road map to renewal
we're going to be on the pathway to
poverty so
you know it's it's
it's not a go
okay thank you so um councillor if i can
summarize there were two hands that went
up that were supporting that idea so can
we move on to your next suggestion
sure um
just in response to uh counselor
putney's view i've never suggested we uh
we look at borrowing i fully agree it's
a it's a full game to borrow for
optics but i'm looking to as he says to
cut [ __ ] so there are two more things
for me
one is the impact of
pulling back on stage two of
streetscapes
so
we uh last year i think authorized an uh
submission significant amount of extra
funding into that project
on the assumption that we would develop
the area from the corner of esk and
kelvin
up to about where the
civic administration building is
and i just can't rationalize at this
hard time while we continue to do that
and my suggestion would be that we
should re-scope that
that re-scoping will probably save us
about five million dollars
and not all of it will fall into next
year but it will certainly pull back the
costings that we have the logic for that
is that the development we've got in the
inner city streetscape project
is to encourage foot traffic more
pedestrians and try to limit the amount
of cars well that just goes against the
whole area beyond calvin street because
we've got two large car parks here which
are going to pull cars in so i think
there's an opportunity there
i also think that um while we um put
together plans long-term plans we don't
always envisage what comes down the
track that follows that
and so sometimes
clawing back or re-scoping is the word i
guess of a project does have some
benefit as well
okay thank you councillor bearing in
mind that we went out and went through a
consultative process on that rhiannon um
have you got a response would we need to
reconsult
in order to
revisit that decision
yes councillor we would need to
reconsult if you change that decision
and i'd also point out as well that
only 0.15
of the rates for next year is relating
to city streets
okay
councillor podinger um
cheer i would actually support
councillor clark's
view that stage two
to me and i'm on the streetscape
committee um and i had to walk down both
don and e street the other day had a bit
of a tour with the construction guys
and they finish up quite nicely
in kelp and kelvin street
and i can't see with
this financial climate that we're in
that 14 million dollars is justified at
all i really can't it's it's landscaping
it's it looks fine i believe that it's
just a bridge too far
and that's my my personal view is if
we're going to drop something not not
not even try and do it half-ass because
that doesn't work either do it right or
not at all so i would just park it
and move on and say
let's see what happens down the track
with finance but
stage two i do not see as essential and
that's my you know
absolute view on that
so can i just
go back to rhiannon to run over the
question i just asked again about
if we want to revisit that
we have to start another consultative
process is that correct yes that is
correct time frame for that would be
how long
it would certainly be after the annual
plan
is complete so we would need to
scope out what the alternative options
are and take those back to the public so
july
off the top of your head and i
appreciate you haven't had any warning
of this but what type of saving is that
likely to
potentially present for the
22-23 year
0.15
0.15
that was not the point it was the
ongoing 16 million 14 million is still
14 million regardless and um you take it
out completely
and that opens up the door for other
projects that we know are around the
corner right well so
a couple of things worth
focusing down on at the moment one is
that we're talking about the rate strike
for next year
nothing beyond that
and that's as far as we can go if we
want to examine
postponing off
the extension of streetscapes we've got
to go through another process it is
possible to do that but i don't see it
as fitting within the time frame of what
we're able to bring into effect just
about just a bit of clarity chair it
says yet to be consulted on in the
language in the in this um
it's easier to be consulted on what does
that refer to
streetscape's two yet to be consulted on
sorry what is that
was in the annual plan document
if you were to give us some resources
um
this
the city streetscapes stage two was part
of the next steps for city block
consultation process
look i'll find it and i'll come back to
you so it's easier to be honest when we
put i think when we put the annual plan
document out counselor that consultation
was still and
had just been finished or was hadn't
quite been finished so that's why the
annual plan document would say yet to be
consulted on right so that's a timing
issue okay but the reason i
am changing the you know supporting
counselor clark here is that back then
when we made that decision
the books all looked a lot different
okay we're not facing this rate increase
so
desperate times desperate measures
councilor but i'll come to you in just a
moment michael
just threw yourself cheer
trying to put my infrastructure hat back
on as well
just in relation to that that project
specifically
it is possible to delay in relation to
that project but i would urge on the
side of caution in relation to delaying
that will increase the cost in relation
to a delay because you've got um
my mike thank you mr day was responding
um because you've got decommissioning
and recommissioning in relation to the
project teams
that's that's point one the second one
is if it was paused completely that is
um that would be where the consultation
aspect comes in the delay
you could do without that consultation
aspect um certain time frame but in
relation to the
um change of scope or d scoping
perspective that would
definitely need to go through the
consultation component thank you
councillor abbott
oh yeah thank you for that michael's
actually covered the very questions that
i was going to ask but are my audio's a
little bit sus did i hear the amount of
0.15 was the cost
correct
for next year
yes yes thank you for that just the
audio's a bit subset yeah thank you
uh just for counsellors if you can
remember to get right into the
microphone and if you are
uh utilizing the safety of a face mask
if you can just bear that in mind with
the volume counselor clank
yep thank you just some further
clarification there i think the finance
people said that the savings
next year across to poor stage two could
be 1.5 percent what seven dollar terms
in physical cash how much if we would
applaud it which is what council of
pontiac said
and that's not my position my position
is that we should do
kelvin between
don and esque because there's
connectivity issues here but we wouldn't
go up s street towards the east so
that's basically saying we'll do part of
stage two and and not the the final part
so i just want to be clear on on
what stage two is actually worth at the
moment i think it's somewhere in excess
of 10 million dollars
11 million something around about that
and if we were to pause it
or to only partly complete what would be
the dollar savings in the next financial
year and the year after so um the
current forecast for spend for that
project for next year is 2.3 million
yeah the total project spend is 13.6 i
don't have to hand council of what's is
likely to be spent in 23 24.
um okay that's fine so given given
council poll your suggestion um if we
were to pause that
with with the concept as michael said
pausing doesn't cause you to consult not
that i i'm worried about consulting
because i think there's a case to be
made
for not doing the full part of stage for
stage two
but if we were just to pause that
that second stage
next year
we would not incur 2.3 million dollars
for the cost
clear
uh mr chair i don't think
my comment was going to be that i think
patricia had given a breakdown of the
rate increase for the next four years
and if she could relocate that that
might be useful so the uh the breakdown
for the rates the next four years for
0.15 for next year
0.52 for 23
24.54 for 2425 and .09 for 25 26.
so so given that we've got a a shortfall
in income
of 1.8 million dollars for this coming
year
and given
the suggestion by councillor parliament
that we put that on pause and even if we
take a year to consult over it doesn't
matter
we could potentially drop our
expenditure by 2.3 million
claire what's the risk to the uh
kakit evelyn thank you for your
attendance
um well michael what's the the potential
risk
around that
thank you chair through yourself um
look i'd
i've already mentioned the
decommissioning and recommissioning
costs in relation to that project
there is a high risk that you won't get
though the particular
project teams back in the region um
anytime soon
that is a is a high risk in relation to
it's a specialized project that we're
doing within the streetscape area
i'd say it would take us some time and
the costs are escalating
daily in relation to those project works
mr chair
i i actually had a visit on don and
esque street this afternoon and i think
that my comment to you would be
michael's saying in
technically correct language that we
would lose
contractors like choppa
choppa who's made it his business to
know the businesses to understand
people's behaviour
to know what our services are that are
under the ground that he needs to take
into account
and
that would be a greater loss
than you might appreciate in dollar
terms
it's that coordination
that is making the project go quite
smoothly at this stage
and which has the opportunity to
continue on
if you don't continue it on
you'll go through that learning process
with a whole new set of contractors
after a different procurement process
and potentially different designers
councillor partner um so just clarifying
are we is this being handed to the
existing contractors or is it being
re-tended stage two
michael
thank you through yourself chair we will
need to go through obviously the tender
process but um as i've highlighted we've
got existing contractors within the
region so
who have got the technical skills so
there will be a case where there'll be
um they will have a
a
a starting ground that is
above other contractors they will need
the other contractors would need to
demonstrate quite significant
improvements in relation to that to
secure that contract that is part of
normal tendering and procurement
contract
final comment on this one for your chair
based on the advice we've just been
given
if we were to go along kelvin between
don and esque as part of stage two
but then we're not to go along s street
in an easterly direction up to the civic
administration building
by the advice we've just been given
i think we conservatively will save 1.1
1.2 million dollars in next year's spend
which is the period we're looking at and
five million dollars over years two
three and four going forward
so while claire says we might lose some
expertise it's not so we and i
understand that when you pause a project
you do lose expertise they go away and
do something else but that's not what i
was suggesting i was suggesting that we
re-scope
stage two
to be completed in the time frames that
it was to be completed but only to do
about half of it and leave the other
half um
pulls permanently for one of the better
words
so
my question comes back to again at that
level of
adjustment does that require re-constant
reconsultation random yeah yes it would
okay
so on so cheer on on the issue of the
reconsultation
um
look the 1.8 million dollars that we are
short in revenue will only impact
on our actual accounts
in in month 12 of next year so that's
june
a year away so we've got plenty time to
consult i don't think many rate payers
would be opposed to um
softening up or rescuing that project
given the nature of it is not an area
where people are gonna uh gonna loiter
or take time anyway given the two car
parks
um so we've got plenty of time to um
to
revisit it with the community because we
don't actually need the money until
month 12.
that's when we'll run short of we're on
balance
council of scalp
thank you through your chair um
again i'm somewhat perplexed
the content of the discussion the
experts we have in the room about
streetscape
um i've actually been through this i've
been through the delay in building
projects and i just can concur with mr
day
today's cost tomorrow's cost and three
years down the track
is significant and
we are actually talking about public
confidence in this council as well which
we shouldn't lose sight of
we made a really interesting decision
last week around the museum which we've
had some very interesting feedback from
the public
some exceptionally interesting feedback
from the public
no one is standing outside this building
today
telling us the rate increase
is actually not acceptable
i haven't seen a placard
i have not seen a placard outside the
front of this building they are not
walking the streets what this community
wants is us to get on
and actually finish the projects we've
got in hand within a reasonable time
frame and a reasonable price and we're
doing due diligence today which is
fantastic
but come on team
it is negligible that what we're talking
about this particular issue
we all agreed some time ago
we all agreed to a person
some time ago around the streetscape
if we delay postpone push out
we've got very very competent financial
people in this room who have given us a
very clear picture
of the of the ongoing costs the
escalated costs and so on
we have contractors on site so
team
this discussion
is absolutely negligible in the big
picture our community wants us to get on
and do things
they are not outside the door with their
placards
actually they've got a bit of confidence
in us to get on and do it
let's actually get on and do it
thank you councillor before i come to
councillor pottinger and then councillor
saper i think out of respect to
submitters it is worth saying that there
were written submissions from people who
were saying that they find that the rate
increase hard to cope with and
0.3 of those people of the 25 000 rate
payers actually said that yep so don't
lose sight of that thank you don't lose
sight of it thank you councillor what
i'm saying is they weren't standing
outside with player cards i just didn't
want to disrespect them by thinking that
their
submissions had not been read councillor
partner uh i guess i'll cut to the quick
actually my intention wasn't to delay it
was to absolutely remove it as being
unnecessary under this financial climate
not delay it actually sorry
e street looks is going to be fantastic
don street is going to be fantastic both
were required with all the other
construction going on made sense there's
no doubt about it
stage two
um
and being on the streetscape committee i
saw how it evolved
and worked in but unfortunately
sometimes you've got to make tough calls
when you're looking further down the
track of what other projects are coming
up rugby park
um some other things
this 14 million dollars i don't see is
worthwhile spending so my
my advice is not to delay it is actually
to delete it and just say that we can't
afford it
thank you councillors i'll soft test the
suggestion shortly council asaper
thanks mr chair and thank you mr
councillor punjab for clarifying that
you actually meant to just get rid of it
all together
because that makes what i'm going to say
easier which is
i'm going to bring us back to why we
ever had a streetscapes project in the
first place
it was part of a
very long-term goal of rebuilding the
heart of the city
actually making it a
people-friendly city that people were
proud of and could move around that was
people friendly not necessarily as car
friendly as it had been but was actually
about improving a streetscape for our
people that project is still
doing that i see absolutely no reason
why we would be discussing delaying it
we have very good and sound advice from
people who are well qualified in their
field that any delay we put into this
project now will cost us mightily in the
future i have also like councillor scout
been involved in and am currently
involved in a very big building project
i know exactly what it means to put
delays into those projects
next year this is talking about a 0.15
part of their rates
this is minor stuff this is like in my
previous profession
hearing boards of trustees
spending
a three-year meeting on a hundred dollar
proposal
this this is just not a sensible
proposal it is not what this council is
about it is not what our heart of the
city project has been about all this
time
it is not what this council has for many
years been proud of that is that we have
reasonable infrastructure that we keep
well maintained
i'm sorry but i just cannot
support any intention that we delay
a project that we all sat around this
table and agreed on
a fairly short time ago and consulted on
with a community who were by and large
very keen
that we developed this as part of our
heart project
thank you now just a point of order
there i did not say delay it was delete
yes no and the councillor did
acknowledge that
councillor emerson
thanks mr chair
i guess for me i come back to what our
ltp
had at the heart of it and that was our
city with heart
and
i think from a strategic point of view
we have to stay focused on that
so for me i think the stage two of the
streetscape work is vital to that
it connects the two major infrastructure
developments that we have
but also i mean even this esk street
part it was going up as far as the st
john's church next door so it's linking
all of this
new stuff together so that we can all
get to enjoy it
and and
enjoy it to its maximum potential
and i'd hate to say that if we do
something
halfway
that we might not get
the outcome that we're looking for in
that
if our goal is a city with heart i
certainly would much rather focus on
that
than things that fell outside of the cbd
thank you
any other speakers
i see your hand up counselor clark but
i'm looking to see if there's anybody
else
thank you i'd still have to have some
comment i'm going to wind the discussion
to a point in a moment though um you've
had a pretty good bite of it sorry
counselor arnold were you
just adjusting the mask
so um
what i'd like to do at this point is to
see what degree of appetite there is for
either
um
suspending or stopping
the the stage two
streetscapes as has been suggested in
two
to different proposals um obviously
councillor clark and councillor
pottinger are in favor of either of
those
um
being examined further is there any
other support for it
counsellor arnold
okay so that's three
did you have something to add councillor
bottinger yes i did and that's purely
about what we're talking about as an
annual report which involves money now
can i just ask out of courtesy
how
we are going to pay for all this it's
nice to hear the sentiments and emotion
about the city with heart but are we so
the answer short answer to your question
is no
uh we're going to go through each of the
item lines right and and discuss them
that way
um
so councillor clark uh did you have
another suggestion
yes i did chair and the final one
will be happy
and that's to run an unbalanced budget
so um we've had advice on this before
but i've had external advice on
unbalanced badges so for those listening
on the live stream an unbalanced budget
is where you start off the beginning of
the year with less income than you have
projected expenditure
and i put it to my colleagues that
actually most years while we forecast
expenditure and forecast revenue
or income we never get it 100 right i'd
define anybody to say that they could do
that it is a bit of a yardstick
sometimes
your revenue can change overnight
and some of your costs can also escalate
especially when you're doing some
project work
so um
in a number of years that i've been
observing council i've noticed that
there have been the occasional year
where we've actually had a uh not a
surplus but a deficit so um
the council has
ended up with less revenue than they
have expenditures towards the end of the
year
and so when they get in that situation
they invariably just take a small
portion of money out of the cash
reserves which avoids borrowing and it
avoids any significant movement and net
debt and avoids
cancelling any projects and then avoids
reducing services to the community or
laying off staff
and what it does is it just props up
that 12th month and you actually run a
bit short on money
and and the reverse also has occurred in
recent times as well where we've
overestimated our expenditure and we've
had a surplus and those services tend to
end up in the
cash investment area where we've got a
nice tidy amount of about 40 and 49
million dollars
so i don't understand why we can't run
an unbalanced budget which allows us to
work through the year manage costs
and review as they even flow
and be prepared at the end of the day to
prop up potentially half a million a
million dollars we might be short on
month 12.
um the local government act allows for
that under sections 100 subsections two
and there are some criteria in there and
i think given our
current fiscal position uh that's what
we should default to if nothing else and
as a final comment i just wanted to
support what council pogba was saying
it's all very well to talk about a city
with a heart and talk about we um
not too long ago agreed to stage two but
at that time we had a we had a financial
picture that said ongoing we would have
four percent a year and we started this
debate with nearly double that amount
so um and and rang is quite quite right
and other speakers have been quite right
as well when you have pressure on that
balance the need for a balanced budget
you sometimes have to look at um
cost cutting in europe and your
expenditure area and while i
don't normally agree with much that
rodney tribe has to say some advice he
gave me recently and said that's the
area you should focus or that you should
run an unbalanced market so that's the
last proposal that i'm putting up thank
you thank you patricia a response around
an unbalanced budget which i'm pretty
sure we're already looking at
so you're correct chair um we are
already looking at an unbalanced budget
to further unbalance it and counselor
clark is correct it is possible to run a
further unbalanced budget but we have to
have a plan about how to get out of the
unbalanced budget
and
because we all know if we run the
unbalanced budget we are going to um put
some costs on to future rate pairs or
future years because we're going to have
to fund that borrowing
and
they might want to mute your microphone
councillor carter
oh sorry councillor clark
it was mrs carter i was hearing in the
background two times lately and once a
week
it is staff's opinion that
to run an unbalanced budget for
operational cost isn't prudent exactly
unless we're in exceptional
circumstances
so my recollection of a previous time
when we ran an unbalanced budget and the
risk that that signals to audit it's
about being able to explain
how it gets to that and what the plan is
beyond it and and that's the point that
you're just reinforcing now that whilst
we're going in with an unbalanced budget
currently there is a plan on how that is
dealt with it becomes a matter of of
degrees and what counselor carter is
sorry god i did it again councillor
clark i will stop before the end of the
meeting nobby i promise you um
what
counselor
clark is suggesting is the degree
of uh unbalance your advice is the risk
that follows that increased degree have
i summarized that mr day
through yourself chair um only step in
because we
we have had an unbalanced budget in
relation to
the 20
20 21 um budgets
that was in relation to a covert subsidy
which we
we in the long term plan we're working
on a back to balanced budget principle
from that
basis which i worked on with the
councillors
that that
this current budget that we've got in
the long term plan was our plan to get
back to that balanced budget now we are
in that position
the imbalance budget that we see today
is in relation to timing of revenue not
actually a true from that perspective
imbalance
and the other thing i just wanted to
clarify in relation to cash and debt
relation to that
it doesn't matter whether you use the
debt or cash it is the net balance from
that perspective you are losing out on
the interest and it is the interest
component that the future rate payers
having to pay for in relation to that so
will will impact on your rates going
forward doesn't matter whether it's
interest revenue or interest cost you
are still having a either loss of
revenue
or an increase cost either way so just
want to clarify that and that's what the
treasury policy is about in relation to
balancing that interest cost to get the
best impact for the council and that's
what the finance team do
on behalf of council
councillor clark yeah thank you chair
just in response to both pieces of
advice here
i do not suggest that we would be doing
further borrowing as patricia said she's
racist before i haven't suggested that
we
can satisfy the imbalance if it occurs
because it may not occur
and we may get more revenue or we may be
able to trim costs
but if we do get that situation i didn't
suggest that we do borrowing that would
lead to pressure on future future
generations i said we potentially could
could
drop into the cash investment area and
take what we needed and i find that
really interesting that michael's now
said that well we would lose the
interest by taking out that that
take out that
investment so there are two things with
that recently a significant amount of
money has gone out of those cash
investments by my assessment 3.8 million
dollars and so i didn't hear this debate
going on when that when the staff
had that maturing
deposit and used it
and secondly um when you say well we
lose out in the interest and that could
affect rates going forward what do you
think an extra 3.15 rates this year is
going to do to ratepayers and the future
generations going forward because this
amount just compounds year after year
after year
so the difference between a 3.5
percent 3.15 increase over above the
four
is way more costly to ratepayers going
forward
than using potentially one million
dollars out of our
cash investment area
sorry the question there was with the
impact of the previous unbalanced budget
was
what
michael or patricia can you just repeat
that again what was the impact of the
previous unbalanced budget
i can't
i had it the other day and i can't
remember
do you recall michael yeah through
yourself the
chair
uh we would need we were needing to be
around i believe the five percent in
relation to the
uh that budget that particularly and we
went through it two percent
that extra three percent um needs to be
recovered over a period of around the
five-year time frame
um estimations uh that
because of that increase you do need to
claw that whole
three percent gap back
plus you also on top of that have to
you've got the interest component
as well as
that component
our estimations are i think that's
around an additional 0.4 from memory
each each year on top of
so you not only need to spread the
additional
3 increasing you also need to spread the
additional 0.4 per annum on top of that
as well so what i'm trying to say is if
you
um delay an um percentage increase you
still need to have that increase so it's
not you cut out 3.5
you'll still need to get that 3.5 to get
back to balance
but you also need to recoup the interest
charge that you're incurring as well so
there's a
double impact and well not double impact
but an impact in relation to the
interest component
for the future rate pass you'll still
need to call back the base percentage
difference
you worship
yes thank you fellow councillors
um
i
was told in my first year in office that
you don't borrow money to pay for the
groceries
and i don't know if that still holds
what the price of groceries have been
what they are but
i think the philosophy holds
uh
the reason i was um took a rather
cowardly approach and abstained from
voting various issues last time
was
i was upset about nigel my mate here
reeling off all these projects the
velodrome and the swimming pool and zero
fees and that
and saying they were all symbols of
failure
um
i think
all right you don't have to defend that
situation
um
the
each of those projects
there was reasons for
like
not putting seats in at the swimming
pool
we just basically ran out of money
and had to cut the project
back
in the short term
but at the end of the day you had to
weigh up all sorts of other factors
and like
um asha's sisters and lives in
switzerland
and they have to pay
um 80 dollars for a half hour let's
listen
which here in splash palace
is more like about thirty dollars
so there's
weighing up all these extras costs and
replications and implications
um i'll be voting to support
councillor cypress
approach to this
challenging situation
thank you councillor skelt
i'm thinking through you cheer just
michael if you wanted to help me just
with the unbalanced budget a little more
would be fair to say throughout new
zealand the councils we
throughout the council structure that
most councils as we sit here today
most councils would be looking at
unbalanced budgets would that be fair
because i can tell you it is
the next step is oh hang on if you're
going to ask the man a question can we
give him a chance to respond i haven't
finished i haven't finished with him yet
um
but no off you going mr day
through yourself yeah there are there
are a number that have got imbalanced
budgets through different reasons
i acknowledge that given the
extraordinary times correct and
but most if not all well actually all of
them have demonstrated ways that they
are bringing that
budget back and all of those are showing
steep increases in relation to their
rates
in years
two three four and five
so i understand that so it wouldn't be
normal
no but they have a process in place
going forward
cool and would it be fair to say i'm not
a lawyer
that most businesses given the last two
or three years would be running
unbalanced budgets would that be fair
because i can give you the answer also
i was going to say through yourself
chair i can't comment on that um
thank you councillor arnold
i've just got one wee comment to make
i'm sitting here listening to all the
all the great um the great minds
um
[Music]
is russia was right you don't borrow
money to buy the groceries but also what
you're doing if you're trying to live
within a budget you make sure you try to
live within that budget that might mean
that you do defer or delay
or put off something that you're going
to spend money on i mean that's just
logic what we can't do what we i don't
think we should do is just
um the way things are at the moment i
think um i'm all for just it's delay um
spending money to keep with in what we
promised we were going to charge our
rate payers
for rates over this next year so that's
why i
am arriving that decision because as
much as russia is dead right it's also
dead right on the other foot that you
don't spend money you don't have
and we can't just go keep going and
asking for more in the right place
because remember it is compounding
thank you councilor sopa
thanks mr chair um i just wanted to ask
michael and patricia for absolute
clarification
so you are saying if we as a council
deliberately further unbalance our
budget
beyond the
explainable unbalancing we know is there
because of the timing difference
that
it will effectively be no saving at all
to our ratepayers who will pay for it
the next year and the following years
with an increase that is part of the
plan for bringing back to balance
in its simplest terms
is that the situation you have just laid
out counselling yes you're correct that
would be that would be the situation
so the the
deliberate unbalancing which would be
putting ourselves as a councillor at
risk of not being a prudent council
will achieve nothing for our rate payers
virtually at all
though it would
stretch
out the cost
they would end up paying in the end
a bigger cost in the next two three four
five
six years
yes
thank you councillor lewis thanks cheers
really simplistic comment over my
the compound and interest on an
unbalanced balanced budget certainly
contributes to ongoing costs for the
ratepayers but the degree of under the
balanced budget is probably the most
crucial thing about that if you've got a
multi multi-million dollar unbed budget
unbalanced budget the dollar value is
quite substantial we've got a very low
unbalanced budget the dollar value is
not as much
so those sort of things have to be taken
into consideration without being too
dramatic about unbalanced budgets i
think
councillor clark i'll come back to you
thank you chair several issues um on the
advice it was given
um
i don't understand why we
have
an unbalanced budget that we're worried
about when we were given some government
subsidy money that we subsequently spent
so we haven't overspent it
we've just spent it and the time frames
are not ideal so it seems to me the
money's coming one year and the
expenditures occurring in next year so
that creates an unbalance to me that's a
red herring because at the end of the
day we should be just looking purely at
what putting that to one side they
should balance out
um and and graham's quite right to say
that
a one million dollar dip in into
or make a an unbalance of one million
dollars is not huge in a budget forecast
of
115 million
um
and so i i just don't can't get my head
around why we
um
so fearful of this unbalanced situation
over two years when logic would tell me
they should balance out you'll get it
under spending one year and an
overspending the other year so it comes
back to what we've committed to i've
heard other councillors say
um
that the unbalanced situation is is now
quite common in the country
and for us to go forward and say well
if we unbalance it by a million or law
forbid two million dollars
and future years we'll have to pay for
it but that's not a true situation
because we've got
um
uh three waters funding
that we can contest our share of that is
5.7 million dollars so if fragments say
our staff were to bid
for that 5.7 million dollars to upgrade
um
rugby park which is about a 5 million
project
we wouldn't have that cost going forward
so that would soften the potential
increases going forward
for our uh for our community so i think
that we're we're not looking at the big
picture here
and i still think that we should run
with an unbalanced budget because in
fact most years we get to a position
where it's unbalanced side either way
thank you councillor so at this point
um i'm aware that
councillor clark and councillor
pottinger and councillor
arnold supporting the idea of further
increasing the undone sorry councillor
bottoms was that right
my um
streetscape two's just my baby okay um
um sorry i i mean we are running an
unbalanced budget but as uh council
lewis pointed out
it's the degree
that you
do it um so
my i will take guidance from our
financial team on how i'm balanced okay
so can i get an indication of who is
supportive of increasing
uh the degree of an unbalanced budget
okay so we've got councillor arnold and
councillor
clark thank you
however i wanted to make sure councillor
clark you felt like your ideas were able
to to
get an earring
yeah thank you chad i think that has
been most helpful um councillors at this
point we do actually have
four recommendations
around where there can be reductions in
the budget made they're up on the screen
from
a to d
would somebody like to
move recommendation 15.
councillor
and seconded by
can we take those individually
yeah okay yep happy with that so shall
we start with a
you're comfortable with that council or
sopa yes i'm very good okay council of
soap is moving uh recommendation a which
is the
uh reduction level of service and parks
and reserve activity to save a hundred
thousand dollars is there a second for
that one
i will just get it on the table
counselor sopa do you want to speak to
that
thank you mr chair i'm presuming that
this has been put forward by staff
because it has been well discussed as
being a very achievable reduction um
that it's not necessarily something that
has been put forward lightly but i would
like to hear from staff as to the
reasoning behind it being put forward
thank you rhiannon
so it is important to note in this
potential reduction that there would be
an impact on the level of service um i'm
not sure if mr giblin is
on soon
he's suffering from covert i so let's go
back a step
um
caroline is here
we made a
request for additional funding in parks
uh and there was a range of reasons for
that caroline do you have that
information here can we just pass that
microphone down to caroline please and
then when it was obvious that we needed
to scrutinise
we felt that there was the opportunity
so
caroline the councillors are looking for
a level of comfort around that suggested
reduction to your budget
so the reduced budget is around reduced
maintenance for consumables and
contractors such as the traffic
management costs
around our roads um we're obviously
going to try and
reduce the visible impact of that the
lower maintenance that that will cause
by increasing our use of permanent
planting and not annuals but that was
basically the request was around traffic
management plans and those type of
contracting costs
any questions counselors
counselor skill
just careful things carolyn just so it
won't affect the actual beautification
of the actual presentation of the parks
or the plots or any of that because i
just note recently that invercargill won
several awards for its presentation of
both its parks in fact the whole city so
can you assure me
can you assure me it's in the resolution
counsellor
it's in the resolution i just want to
hear carolyn to tell me that herself
you can assure me karen
i can aim to assure you that that will
be that will not occur we are trying to
minimize any impact
minimize is an interesting word thank
you
councillor edmondson
is it right this isn't really a question
it's more a comment
um
given that people care so much about our
parks and the spaces that we
are responsible for as a council and
that the parks
team does a fantastic job of looking
after
i'm not sure i want to see a reduction
in level of service in that area
um
because we all know that from time to
time people do make comments about weeds
being in places that they shouldn't be
and
roundabouts that aren't as pretty as
they should be and that sort of thing
and
i think
i just feel like that's something that
we should maintain
um in terms of
that level of service so i will be
voting against this
councillor pottinger then councillor
arnold
look just following on um councillor
munson mentioned a good point about
roundabouts now that that was very
topical um
um not so long ago the condition of the
roundabouts and uh here we are trying to
um so
they negate they're looking after them
so look
yeah i'm i'm with councillor munson on
this um i think parks do an amazing job
on the budget they have so i'm not
interfering with it
okay i'm just going to remind everybody
that you can't get a reduction in rates
without a reduction in service
somewhere so we'll wait for the magic
councillor arnold thank you yeah i just
have to agree with
my colleagues over there inside here i
just think that
for a
an area that has such a huge budget
to actually make the most visible thing
um
the unkept them all the things going to
suffer is we've become crazy so i'm sort
of against it as well because i mean the
plots and the curbs are the most visible
thing in the city so
and they'll be pretty bad in recent
times and i would hate to see that
for anyway for any reason um
no i would have to use this as well
there are other ways to save money
councillor rabbit then councillor
crackit
yes so thank you for that i just
appreciate what others have said about
the appearance of the plots and things
and one of the big things that i always
hear is the annuals the annuals that
flower and i've heard that they are
going to now perhaps be replaced by
perennials or something
and i think the annuals need to come
back and they need to be shown
so i'll be voting against that as well
councillor crackit
actually don't worry that's fun
councillor carter
sorry i didn't
that's three in a row there's a
compulsory gin in the clubhouse for that
one
yeah yeah right back
um
and while i while i support um
my colleagues i'm not sure i agree with
your assumption that if we want to get a
reduction in rates we have to have a
reduction in service delivery i don't
agree with that we've got lots of other
levers we can use without cutting into
services
i think one of the things that we need
to do beyond streetscape is to maintain
and improve the beautification of the
city so any cutting into the park's
reserve budget is not the way to
keep our rates down and it's actually
not a reduction in rates it's actually
avoiding by the rates increases we
promised last year
so so i'll be uh
as councillor
carter i'll be um
voting against that hundred thousand
you'll get two votes
yeah thank you
any other council is wishing to speak to
the emotion
if not we have a motion on the table for
a
further reduction in the level of
service within parks and reserves with a
saving of a hundred thousand dollars all
in favor say aye aye
against okay
we have to call for a show of hands
there sorry all those in favor of the
reduction if you could raise your right
hand please
one two
three
that's it thank you the motion is
carried i just couldn't tell from the
volume lotion
sorry
who was that you said the person was
carried
sorry the motion was uh the motion has
lost my uh yes i apologize thank you
very much it's been a long day well
spotted well spotted
sneaky chairman
well said
councillor castillo
sorry lindsey was there i had to go for
it
uh so that remains within the budget
then the next item is a reduction in the
budget for city centre activation from
250 to 50 000
uh
thanks counselor cricket did you have
your hand up i did thank you um i just
wanted to talk to this and that um i
believe this is an area that we can see
a minor saving just in that um with
investors very heavily in the city city
centre and a lot of that is actually
going to start to um be realized as
everything begins to open and and
attracts its own um it has its own vibe
and its own buzz about it so i think
that for some time reducing that while
that we can just let them shine for
themselves is probably a wise decision
councillor amundsen
yeah just a question i'm just wondering
is this a one-off reduction
um so that 0.33 will come back into the
rates in the following financial year so
we're just doing i guess a temporary
mr chair this was a one-off increase i
believe
there is a
ongoing amount separately funded for the
coordinator yeah yes but
am i right this was additional
activation because of what we were
you know what was happening
in the cbd and this will pull it out
there's still
i have to go and we i can't remember
what there is the following year but
there is this is all the vlog the short
but the activation fund isn't sorry to
speak out of turn
councillor podinger um again some
clarity needed here the um i was aware
of being on the streetscapes committee
is that there was activation for the
affected shops that were down the north
side of east street and around the areas
of don they were impacted by the
construction site so is that the same
sort of activation fund we're talking
about here
yes okay so basically
the the place is not open
uh east street can i get some clarity on
when history is going to be fully
fully drive through open
happening 2023 2023 so look we've
we've told the um
i mean it's a genuine cut but we have
told the
the the retailers in that vicinity that
we are going to be helping them
out with uh with activation because
of the you know the grief the
inconvenience they've been put to and i
i can't really see that why this has
been put forward to us when we've sort
of done a deal with them
so i don't know why it's there
richard
just to give you some clarity when we
were talking about this line there is no
agreed service level at this point that
we're talking about so we're talking
about a budget that we looked at for the
entire year and then looked at when the
opening and opportunities for activation
would actually happen in the next
financial year and we don't believe
there's not actually
as big a window as what we originally
thought of time to spend uh activating
we've also identified that there are a
number of
units within council that have a desire
to take their product out to the streets
to be engaged for outreach and we can
leverage some of that budget and some of
that funding to get better bang for our
buck we don't want
to be having an activation here and also
having another unit trying to promote
themselves or do an activation
externally we can combine the two of
them so given the shorter window of
opportunity for activations and the
willingness for other
departments to contribute to that we
believe that we can still
do the mitigation do the activation of
the site without having to use all that
money
recognizing there is also another
opportunity after next financial year to
rediscuss the impact of activations
going forward
as long as we are consistent with what
we have promised the retailers that we
are doing that's all i'm worried about
because you know i've talked we've
talked to those during consultation
and this is important
that we're not pulling anything
so if i can get insurance on that
but i i still can't see
you've heard an answer whereby
funds for activity
for activation will
be reassigned from within other budgets
is that accurate
not quite and not so much reassigned but
there's a willingness for other people
to contribute to this sort of
inactivation
so whether it's going to deliver the
same we can't because we haven't
demonstrated the the extent to the
service level previously
what we're saying is there's a smaller
amount of money and there's a desire for
people to work on it so it's just
becomes what gets programmed so the
change might be the sorts of activations
but there's no reason with going into it
with our eyes wide open why the impact
can't be just as good with a lesser
amount so are the carry forwards that
are likely to come from this
currently sorry not careful it's meaning
the um
going forward not actually
financial carry forwards
mr chair you do highlight the fact that
this advice has come forward on the
basis that the budget has not been fully
expended in this financial year if
council had concerns it could move an
amendment to a different amount
michael
um
through yourself i just wanted to
clarify that this fund is a one-off as
in it does have ongoing and therefore
will come in and go um
saving will come in next year and go
back in the year after because the 250
is in
for the next financial year and for a
number of years after to
because it was seen at the time of
putting the fun in fund in by council
that this fund would be required for a
number of years
not as a one-off impact but would need
to revitalize that in a city over a
number of years that was in the original
resolution from council when they put
this in
so
we what's being proposed is around the
timing in relation to that so
we're suggesting the 50 000 is required
next year because of the timing in
relation to the
um start of the
or the completion of the project and
then it would go back up to the 250 in
the following year uh from that
perspective
to be sort through about how can be
actually utilized in that year so that
probably addresses councillor
pottinger's question right um going back
up no it doesn't i i'm really seeking is
that there is no change in level of
activation that the retailers and
escondon are getting now that's the
assurance i need
that this
uh
b is not going to change that
richard do you want to handle that
i cannot see a described level of
service for that amount it was a budget
envelope that we sort of committed to
addressing the mitigation for the impact
to those retailers so it's it comes back
down to now about making sensible and
clever decisions about how we activate
to achieve that it was never an itemized
you know
uh amount for so many activations or so
many approach so we've got a smaller
budget but a much smaller window to
operate within so we don't need it for
the entire year
is the short answer
so i've got councillor crackit then
councillor scout then councillor lewis
um thank you council ludlow um i think
and
it's
important to me that the
retailers certainly feel like we're
doing everything we can to ensure that
there's stuff there for citizen
activation and we have been working with
them um and i know of course you sit on
that great council of pottinger with the
stakeholders
um i think it's really important to note
that like uh richard said that the
envelope of time that we're operating
with for the next financial year for
that 50 000 is quite small but also
you've made the point councillor
pottinger that the when when will that
street open and be functional we do have
an opening date for half of the street
and for the car park to be delivering
people um into that half of the street
so although you may not be able to use
the other half within that window that
funding that's available there i think
would be uncomfortable with it being
sufficient that we like you said we can
work together and making
the best use of it within that small
window and then
obviously strategize to understand how
the fund can be best used in future
counselor skill thank you thank you
thanks michael for the explanation and
richard also i guess my concern and i'm
a little bit with councillor pottinger
in the sense of
you've talked about time frames so we're
obviously narrowing down are we talking
about a because we don't know well i
don't know three months or a six months
narrowed time frame or that may be
confidential as we sit here today i'm
not sure
but when i look at that figure and i
look at activations and
um
bringing people into the city we have an
opportunity to have the whiz-bang for
whatever short period of time that may
be
we have a commitment as accounts and we
sat here with our retailers and gave
them that commitment
my concern would be if
given if it's a six-month time frame
when we look at 50k
from the event industry that's quite um
that's not a lot of money to be fair to
be giving the support structures
uh to make it whiz bang
if that's if that's what the aim is the
council is and i believe it is
so i just need a little bit of
confidence from you richard that within
time frames because i don't know
that um we're gonna get the whiz-bang
and get a good bang for our buck
and make those retailers really happy
and we get those people into those
central areas so sorry richard can you
perhaps help me with that through mr
chair i probably can't give the clarity
in which you're wanting uh today in
terms of what i'm hearing is you'll want
to know what type of activations they
would be yeah in terms of the window
um consider and this is not referring to
any specific opening dates or anything
but
uh it was commented a little while ago
to me and i thought it was quite a good
sort of snapshot
really it's we're talking um between
labor day and anzac day is the
envelope where you can have an outdoor
event safely and
and meaningful so that's actually a very
small part of the year and given then
where our decision about when is opening
and when we can activate it it narrows
it down
even further your question about what is
whisping that is something that still
needs to be worked through with the
stakeholders with the effect of people
to understand what their needs really
are and then we design something for
that so to go on and just think it's an
an event as such might not actually
deliver the outcomes those businesses
want so we've just got to still clarify
what that is and then cut our cloth to
suit
thank you that helps thank you
councillor lewis i'm fine now thank you
okay
councillor clark
thank you chad just clarification on two
points um i didn't pick up
um the second part of what richie was
saying labor day and
anzac day
antique day yes thank you and the other
issue was
i think uh council podge asked
when was s street open and reply was
2023 well
um
can you firm that up as to roughly when
in 2023 richard
just through you mr i just want to just
re-clarify what i said between those two
public holidays i'm just uh giving you a
snapshot of when outdoor events are
likely to be
feasible to do i wasn't giving any set
dates about project completion or
anything like that just wanted to
clarify cheers fully understand that
but but when you say the s3 is going to
be open at 2023 do you want to give us
some sort of uh more certainty to that
are we talking about i think that kind
of came from clear yes it missed uh mr
chair that comment came from me
uh respectfully politely no i do not
wish to give you any greater
um clarity on it i believe there are
still commercials around that
and i think you are having a
conversation with your icl chair on ycl
board member on thursday that may be a
question for him
so
any other questions or comments around
the motion which is a reduction
from 250 to 50 000 for next year only
if not those in support of the motion if
you could raise your hand
one two three four five six
seven
those
uh against
one two three four five
six yes and uh two on loans yeah i
believe there are
i counted thirteen earlier um
two four five six eight ten thirteen
seven four six events thank you motion
is carried
next item is c
you're calling for division
that's what you'd need to do okay
councillor scout has called for division
so those who supported the motion if you
could raise your hand again
it was just please on the screen
thank you thank you
so you're comfortable working out the
other vote from there thank you
um
c the reduction of staff budget of 160
achieved through uh management of
recruitment uh who wants to speak to
this i'll move that
move councillor sopa secondary
councillor cracker
surfing for questions comments
discussion
counselor partner i'd just like to say
it's not our role from governance to
cross into management so i accept what
they put up there
it's only taken how long
could we have that in writing please
sign them blood i believe i believe the
meeting is recorded thanks councillor in
your comments
uh i'll put the motion all in favor aye
aye
against councillor scout
do you like your vote recorded thank you
thank you
that brings us to item d reduction of
the community well-being fund by fifty
thousand dollars
councillor lewis thank you chair
i'm actually against this um
zero point eight percent can i get a
mover first of all sorry move councillor
soper as a resector for the motion
council let's go now
and talk to it thank you very much
i'm against this because whilst it
doesn't
result in a minimal reduction in rates
0.08
it depends how the maths
is done because i think that the
warm
homes trust money might be coming across
to this particular
community will be in fund at some stage
which is 50 000. so anyway it depends if
it doesn't it doesn't really matter
depends how the denominator is done for
the mathematics
a reduction of 50 000 taken out of the
500 000
the community wellbeing fund has will
affect
up to 10 percent
the
it's disproportionate the effect on our
city of hearts in my mind
as chair of the community wellbeing fund
sometimes there is a bit of a struggle
to do the budget
around
the well-meaning people who apply for
various events
functions and things around the town
with this extra 10 reduction it's going
to be more difficult
and the thought is in my mind also the
the city center activation reduction in
money might result in some extra
applications for events around the city
around about that time
straight from the community well being
funded so this is why i would be against
the reduction
thank you rhiann can you just make some
clarification around the warm homes
funding
yes so as this committee received i
think back in march a adjustment to the
grants
as part of the process to
formalize or regulate regularize would
be a better way of putting it
applications to the long term plan
you made the decision to move that
additional funding of 50 000 that was
originally as part of the long-term plan
for the southern warm homes trust so
that they would apply to the community
well-being fund in the future
so this reduction here would reduce the
fund down from 550 000 to back to 500
000.
as it noted it it would
mean that the committee would need to
manage that funding available over the
year
thank you
counselor amundsen councillor actually
no sorry counselor cracker i'll go to
you because i realize you have to go
thank you um
my
uh comment is much in line with um
councillor lois and i'd really like to
support him given that he i have sat on
this community well-being fund alongside
him for quite some time
um
we have just passed a resolution to
reduce the city center activation but
the community well-being fund actually
has waiting within its um
scoring framework towards city centre
activation itself so when those
applicants come um to apply to us for
funding we apply waiting for the event
to be held in a city and they're
actually community-driven
uh reasons or community-driven
activations rather than us telling the
city what it what it needs so i'm
perfectly comfortable with the fund
remaining as it is with the
50 000 um rather than reducing it
thank you councillor emerson then
councillor scout
yeah i guess i'm going to follow the
leader
on this one and i guess for me the
community wellbeing fund the purpose of
it is to help look after our community
and i think we all
assume or suspect that we're going to be
heading into some times of hardship for
our community so this fund is going to
be in more demand than ever and i guess
whilst on one hand we can think about
lower rates being helpful for our
community actually having this fund
is equally
as helpful for our community so i would
be in favor of keeping this at the
existing amount and we'll be voting
against it councillor scout thank you i
can only endorse council lewis cricket
and
rebecca's comments this fund's actually
woefully inadequate to be honest in the
sense of cr if you look across new
zealand per pop we'd be the worst in the
country in the sense of this particular
fund for our community so i i will be
absolutely voting against it
uh councillor lewis i can if i can ask a
question of you because i've only said
it on one of these meetings the um
is there
does your committee run carry forwards
no it doesn't no no so anything that's
not
claimed spent is not a carry forward so
it's not an extra charge right here
you don't build a wall no we don't
unfortunately thank you
councillor scout just on that though i
have asked mr day and i know he's
working on it just to look at that
process going forward and we did have a
discussion a couple of months ago just
whether that would be possible because
um i just think it's an opportunity
going forward microcontrollers can any
stage amend its rules yeah so michael
has had a look at that always looking at
that yes yes so that's a work in
progress thank you thank you
through yourself chair so the way the
committee works at the moment if there
is a multi-year a large project
they can they can bid for a multi-year
component but they would need to
demonstrate that through the committee
so there is a chance for the more
significant events to apply but then
they would need to be very forward
in their thinking in relation to their
application but that is one mechanism
they can do it and they apply for it
over the multiple years
thank you if i could be the last speaker
on this one if that suits your chair um
thank you for that clarifications today
but that also put strain on on the
subsequent years of course because that
money is designated for those particular
well-meaning meaning events functions
whatever it have to be so there's less
money but we can't run this well-being
on less money
if we looked at the events i'm sure
you're quite aware because you would
have read the agendas coming through the
will
meaning projects this has helped fund
doesn't fund them all but it's widely
diversed from bluffton for cargo from
music
to art et cetera et cetera many many
will
mean in world will be meaning functions
around the city and it would be a shame
in my mind to lose another fifty
thousand dollars from this fund
thank you
thank you
thank you so uh
there was a motion
uh moved by councillor soper seconded by
councillor scout for the reduction in
the community wellbeing fund i'll put
the motion all in favor aye right
against
no no no we
the vote is for a reduction
okay so if you want to stay where it is
you will be a no
so those in favor of the reduction i i i
against no no
okay that motion is lost
which brings us to the end of everything
that we have on the plate sorry
councillor pottinger just the you said
this was the opportunity in
section 15
to bring in
the dark horse go for it
so i've i've sent uh
um it was actually rhiannon that sent me
the table so i fired that back during
our
use of legitimate use of electronic
devices
um to patricia
and she has the table there and that
lists
a clear ets fee
and then less lists a gate fee that
includes an ets fee
and it all adds up to 699 170
and that's what i dispute because you
can't charge ets twice
i'm just getting as we speak the answers
from staff
which i will need some time to go
through so
um
so you're saying the table is wrong if
the table's wrong i'm not saying the
table is wrong i'm just trying to
clarify the basis behind the table being
put together
which mr chair i think my comment would
be
that it's
we the staff are unable to give you
advice on which you can rely
and make decisions
uh at this stage other than the advice
that you have already been given
i have asked the staff whether we can do
more work the difficulty is covert
and
changed personnel
and various and different understandings
that really means we need to take this
one carefully
councillors open
thanks mr chair to speed up this
particular issue could we perhaps add a
d
to 15
[Music]
that says something along the lines of
an e sorry
well
well considering we've um
not incorporated one of them it might be
a d but let's not argue um if we added
an e that perhaps said something along
the lines of
authorised staff to investigate
the matter of the ets
charge within the waste net charging or
whatever words are going to cover it
so that staff can come back to us
i'll let staff ponder that for a moment
while i go to councillor clark
thank you chair just two quick
reflections and fully support what ring
is raised
um and i'm not sure that the uh
lack of staff through code but i think
is a suitable excuse uh i've been
partying to meetings at least a week ago
possibly two weeks ago when he phrased
this issue and given that we're
factoring in some
considerations about rate increases i
don't think it was a big ask to have
some advice today
and the other issue for me is just to
acknowledge that with two of those
recommendations from staff being um
being lost in the vote our strike
rate strike going forward is now 7.4
oh good no i'm getting a head shake it's
not point four so your maths might be uh
look i'll just take issue with the first
one
they were proposing seven point one five
um which factored in those
uh four reductions a b c and d so two of
them were lost so you've got it
shortened right now no they didn't know
that seven point one five did not factor
in those four that was always going to
be less
okay that's fine
7.15 is now less what we have passed in
15. so before i come to patricia for an
answer around what the proposed
reduction is about to be and then we'll
come back to clarity around
waste net
some of the questions around the ets
were really only raised today
and there are people off sick so
to say that you don't accept that staff
could have had everything the questions
that were um
asked today
uh hadn't been signaled previously so
that i i'd take issue with that however
around the reduction patricia
um as we're sitting now it is 6.53 as
the rate's increased so it's dropped
from 7.15
to
6.53
okay
councillor pottinger um
so is the way ford chair
that you will take are you looking have
we got the opportunity when we bring
this to council
or that that's the next step isn't it
for adoption our recommendation it's the
rate strike um
mrs hadley there was a suggestion from
councillor soper around advice from
staff and a potential aide do you have a
position on
how best to manage
the clarity that we're looking for
around the waste net charging
mr chair i think the best i could offer
you today
is to say that we will come back to you
and give you an update on the 14.
i'm
i can only apologize but note that
um
there's some intricacies in this process
that haven't been
um
fully mastered by existing by staff who
have joined us in
more recent times
and some of the questions have been
difficult to unpick exactly what is
being asked of
the last thing i want to do is give you
misleading information
i did ask whether we'd be able to get to
uh
clarity on it by the 14th of june and
the initial answer i got was i'm not
sure about that
but i understand council's interest and
we will do our best
and
what you can be confident of is that we
won't be asking for more
i um
i just wanted to double check with
patricia about 6.53
and she says yes
um
but i
we need that time so it is possible that
at the regular ppp meeting on june 14th
which is prior to the rates strike at
full council we have to be able to
provide clarity around that one item
correct and make an amendment at that
point otherwise everything else we have
decided tonight
councillor pottinger now just as chair
of infrastructure can i make a
suggestion that we have an
infrastructure meeting
um you've got one next week but i'm not
sure from what
i'm just saying that
the key things that we're after and i
don't believe the questions are
complicated because
the first question was has the ets been
included twice it's pretty
straightforward second question was
really to do with the tonnage why are we
predicting extra tonnage when all the
figures i have
show absolute consistency and tonnage so
third question is
the fund the administration fee that
wasteneck collects
on the council's behalf so it collects
it for gore
sdc and for us and in the past i've been
on wasteland for nine years
in my earlier life
and that money was always used
we're talking 140 000 a year for this
city as a buffer for when you had the
fluctuations
and and that's what it was used for so
they are the three questions what is the
fund currently with waste net that we
are
a substantial
owner of
has the ets been asked twice and are the
tonnages correct
right so those come back to the
questions that you raised at the chairs
meeting today and the chief executive at
that point gave an assurance that there
would be a paper coming back
um and do you want to give a rough
timeline around that so i i think there
are two separate issues mr chen i agree
okay so the first thing is there is an
infrastructure committee meeting next
week but quite frankly there are four
working days
because there is a
um public holiday
some of the staff are off with covert
and there is a need to involve
infrastructure staff and financial staff
it's the end of year
and so we've had quite a few of our
other ccos and we are involved in annual
report preparation as well
so discussing the matter infrastructure
not only sits outside the issue of the
budget and the delegations around the
annual plan
but we won't have the information ready
in a way that will be assisting to a
discussion
i
am hoping to get you information for the
14th in relation to the annual plan
alone
and that may answer the questions that
counselor potential has asked or it may
be that that needs to come back to a
future infrastructure meeting in
addition so there's two parts to it
there may be two parts to it
okay councillor cracker do you need to
thank you councillor ludlow um from a
waste net perspective i'm confident that
we will find out the answer to this the
process like counselor ludlow has
outlined we will still get another
bite at the apple for want of a better
sense of terminology we will get the
officer information in due time before
we have time to to strike the rates so
i'm comfortable that we'll have time to
find that information
right now i have to go and be on mum
duty but um with that yeah i'm just
conveying my my comfortability
before i take my leave
thank you cheers have a comfortable
evening
yes
councillor
thanks mr chia i was just going to
comment that considering we have passed
in in recommendation 15 a recommendation
to council to to adopt the annual plan
incorporating
those subparts we passed the only
realistic answer on that one issue of
the ets
the only realistic way we can deal with
that is at that meeting on the 14th and
i would support your suggestion that
that is where it is dealt with
that would then allow on that one
issue
a a minor amendment to the
recommendation we have actually passed
to council
and the rest of the waste net issues
that have been raised obviously will
take more time which we have that time
to take
thank you councillor abbott live mike
were you wanting to say something
oh no no sorry sorry i didn't realize
it's not councillor clark
just the final reflection so there's no
surprises for my colleagues
if the
annual plan is adopted with a six point
five three percent increase i will be
okay
noted thank you
councillors that's as far as we can take
it this evening i think sorry what have
we got for em we didn't have uh a motion
come forward there was a suggestion
or did you i'm happy to move it as as a
so what was the mission i'm i'm
suggesting that you might want to note
that further advice
may come forward on the 14th of june
because i think you need it so that
you've not
around waste net funding around waste
charges thank you i'm happy to move that
because
15
is there a second for that councillor
thank you
any other comments around that
we will get that clarity
i'll put the motion all in favor aye aye
against
none carried thank you counselors that
brings us to the end of this evening's
meeting um
uh wins and losses all round but
you know that's that's the process and
and that's democracy and i thank you